this is just a reminder that beauty standards are forever changing
forever they're
they're always moving the goal post to keep us on our toes
at one time this was the beauty standard
in 19th century Persia
this was
this was everything
so even if you look like this today
hmm
rocket own that shit
don't let a man tell you what the fuck beauty means
because clearly they do find everything beauty
that's what they don't want you to know
they think all of us are beautiful
sure they're gonna rank us
I prefer that one
or that one or that one
but would they rather have their dick in their hand
no no
they wouldn't
so at the end of the fucking day
we are beautiful
they know that
what they want is for us to not know that
they want us to not think that
they want us to be insecure about everything
not realising we see what the fuck's going on out here
all you gotta do is have a little bit of fucking confidence
own who the fuck you are
because I guarantee you there's somebody that's really fucking into it
and you do not have to settle for shit